the Washington Redskins new wide
receiver is giving props to Colin
Kaepernick for getting signed jordan vce
was at the workout with Kaepernick last
month in Atlanta he caught this
incredible passion yeah incredible catch
from the former San Francisco 49ers
quarterback video of the catch scored
about four and four and a half million
views on Twitter VC tells the Washington
Post he really believes the opportunity
to catch passes from Kaepernick helped
him earn a spot on the Redskins practice
squad yeah
as for Kaepernick though he has not
heard back from the end he's somebody
got signed out of that one no easy says
Thank You mr. Capra now but Kaepernick
has no interest from any NFL team at all
which I was really remarkable yeah yeah
because everybody that watched him said
he was really good but the way it was
handled the people say on his side was
problematic for a lot of coaches and
players who were watching yeah
congratulations to Jordan BC though yeah
right he's getting a big shout out